bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au parlement européen à bruxelles pour
une nouvelle émission d'europe hebdo et
dans cette émission direction la suisse
reportage le dépit des travailleurs
frontaliers français après la votation
suisse sur l'immigration nous suivrons
pascal ria télé française chaque jour
elle prend le bus pour traverser la
frontière elle travaille près de genève
après le référendum qui veut instaurer
des quotas pour les travailleurs
étrangers elle est inquiète
il ya aussi bruxelles qui hausse le ton
les conséquences de cette votation c'est
ce que nous allons voir dans cette
émission mais avant un tout autre sujet
qui sera le nouveau président de la
commission européenne nouveauté cette
fois il sera forcément issu du parti qui
aura gagné les élections européennes qui
auront lieu en france vous le savez le
25 mai prochain à l'état des lieux des
candidats en lice avant de retrouver
l'un d'eux guy verhofstadt c'est le chef
de file des libéraux et vous allez le
voir il n'a pas la langue dans sa poche
il est à la tête de la commission depuis
dix ans et son poste fait l'objet de
toutes les convoitises
le 1er novembre prochain josé manuel
barosso cédera sa place après deux
mandats en tant que chef de l'exécutif
européen
à gauche le parti socialiste européen a
déjà tranché
si cette formation arrive en tête des
élections en mai prochain ce sera à
l'allemand martin schulz actuel
président du parlement européen qui
prendra la tête de la commission
chez les verts le français josé bové et
l'allemande ce cas qu'est leur mèneront
en duo la campagne le grec
alexis tsipras a été choisi pour
représenter la gauche radicale à droite
au parti populaire européen la bataille
sera rude entre le commissaire européen
michel barnier
l'ex premier ministre luxembourgeois
jean claude juncker où l'ancien premier
ministre letton valdis dombrovskis au
centre c'est le belge guy verhofstadt
qui représentera les libéraux c'est à
fédéraliste convaincu
il prône la création des états unis
l'europe premier ministre de belgique
pendant neuf ans guy verhofstadt qui
parle français anglais allemand
néerlandais et italien va donc pouvoir
défendre la cause fédéraliste son
principal combat désormais une très
bonne nouvelle pour le débat des
européennes le chef de file centriste
est très clivant et ne dites pas à dire
que l'europe actuelle fonctionne mal
cela promet de bons clash face notamment
à martin schulz qui n'a pas non plus sa
langue dans sa poche
bien sûr il y a peu de chances que les
centristes l'emportent aux élections
européennes tant la droite et la gauche
domine en europe
pas la moindre chance de devenir
président la commission européenne et
verhofstadt
pourquoi il va t'il alors pour se
positionner pour après constituer un
grand groupe politique qui soit le
troisième groupe du parlement européen
un groupe absolument incontournable qui
lui permettrait ainsi de devenir le
prochain président du parlement européen
affaire à suivre
alors nous avons été rejoints sur ce
plateau par guy verhofstadt bonjour si
un premier ministre de belgique de 1999
à 2008 eurodéputés candidat des libéraux
à la présidence de la commission
européenne devant le petit sujet
première question toute simple vous y
allez dans cette bataille à la
présidence de la commission européenne
pour gagner nous c'est un jeu de billard
comme certains analystes le dise à jeu
de billard à trois bandes et vous vous
seriez autres choses la présidence du
parlement européen ont gagné parce que
en fait la procédure est tout à fait
nouveau la procédure a qui est prévu
dans les traités dit que le président à
la commission doit avoir d'année à lui
une majorité de députés
or on sait déjà que ni le ppe ni les
socialistes peuvent avoir une majorité
dans ce parlement
donc on aura besoin d'une troisième gros
c'est à dire des libéraux et des
démocrates et les plus forts nous sommes
dans cette élection le plus de change
qu'on a dans la négociation pour obtenir
ce poste de président d atomic quand
même le le prochain président de la
commission européenne y sera issu du
parti qui aura gagné les élections
européennes avec mais on peut gagner les
élections ne sont pas étant le premier
parti et je suis persuadé ce que le
programme qu'on va présenter face et
duire certainement une grande partie des
citoyens en europe puisque on va se
positionner comme vraiment l'alternative
pour tout les mouvements populistes
nationalistes eurosceptiques qu'on voit
naître à gauche et à droite
en europe justement parce que nous
disions aux citoyens que c'était un
mensonge de dire qu'on va résoudre les
problèmes en europe en se retranchant
derrière la frontera en 2009 la
participation aux élections européennes
s'étaient 43% 43 % seulement vous avez
dit dans votre discours qu'il fallait
mener une immense bataille c'est quoi
votre plan d' attaque pour mener cette
belle blonde a taxé que partout en
europe par exemple en france avec la
liste alternative mais aussi en italie
où il va y avoir une autre liste en dans
tous les pays ont fait pologne tchéquie
et la peur la grèce aussi on va
présenter des nouveaux liste sont des
listes qui sont centristes
fort mist qui au même moment vont
présenter un projet pour l'avenir de
l'union européenne et ce sera un projet
avec plus d'intégration parce qu'on a
besoin de ça on peut pas avoir la
monnaie unique d'une part et puis ne pas
avoir une union économique fiscale et
politique
et c'est ça qu'est la crise a vraiment
démontré la deuxième chose qu'on va dire
c'est que ce n'est pas les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement qui peuvent gouverner
l'union européenne ce a mal tourné la
dernière année ce qu'il faut c'est
vraiment un système communautaire
démocratisé avec un gouvernement
européen contrôlé par un parlement
européen qui doit faire notre avis on va
parler de nombreux européens en ce
moment le son ont peur on sent un repli
national en france un récent sondage a
dit que les français voulaient plus de
pouvoir pour les états nationaux - au
détriment de 2,2 de l'europe qui serait
contre l inverse on a l'impression que
ce sont des eurosceptiques ou europhobes
qu'ils vont gagner chaque champion c'est
l'excès mais c'est leur sphère politique
qui aujourd'hui trône cet esprit
européenne voulait on vivait brûlé et
donc iihf
il faut dire aux français que c'est un
mensonge de penser qu'on peut résoudre
par exemple le changement climatique
comme on peut le résoudre à l'intérieur
seuls des frontières françaises c'est
impossible c'est quelque chose de
transnationales ou par exemple comment
voulez convaincre la migration tri vient
du nord d'afrique comme on veut on veut
résoudre ce niveau national non c'est au
niveau continental et au niveau européen
qu'il faut le faire ou par exemple
dernier exemple les produits toxiques
financier qui viennent de l'autre côté
de l'océan atlantique
comment on va aller se protéger contre
l'importation de ces produits tout seul
c'est impossible même info il faut je
dire à réinventer la souveraineté mais
au niveau européen d'accord vous n'êtes
pas le seul candidat y aura un candidat
du ppe des conservateurs elle sera
désignée en mai le mois prochain il y
aura il ya aussi le candidat socialiste
martin schulz
il est venu dans ma banlieue parisienne
essaie de convaincre les jeunes de son
projet européen hélas son argument je
vous propose de l'écouter et vous
réagissez juste après
tous les initiatives législatives à
bruxelles sont des initiatives de la
commission européenne nous conte
parlement européen on nous a privés du
droit de prendre des initiatives
législatives personne peut priver
comportement et ses collègues à
l'assemblée nationale de prendre les
initiatives pour le des lois en france
normalement un député est élu pour soi
nous on a plus nous priver de ce droit
nous luttons pour cela depuis des années
mais maintenant c'est le parlement qui
vote le président de la commission c'est
à dire ils vont le président de
l'institution qui a le droit d'initier
des lois c'est à dire il ya un autre
lien maintenant entre le parlement
européen et ceux qui ont le droit
d'initiative s'en rend à cette élection
européenne au mois le 25 mai une
importance énorme parce que les
électeurs pour la première fois vote des
députés qui peut ensuite pour un
président de la commission voilà martine
chose qui s'insurge que les députés
européens n'est pas l'initiative pour
l'élaboration des textes c'est la
commission est ce que c'est pas ça qui
casse un peu le lien leur politique le
lien entre les électeurs et leurs
institutions repères et mais le problème
la dernière année a surtout été le fait
que la commission européenne n'a pas
utilisé son droit d'initiative pour
justement présenter des projets des
alternatives et des solutions à la crise
et journée eu des bagarres avec avec le
président actuel monsieur barroso à
chaque fois j'ai dit mais pourquoi vous
avez un bon plan justement pour créer
par exemple la gouvernance économique
dans la zone euro dont on a besoin le
plus vite possible mais il faut le
mettre sur la table du conseil et du
parlement sous forme d'un pack dialogue
c'est les états le concert c'est sûr
magne c'est surtout une manque de
courage du côté du président de la
commission qui d'après ce qu'il fait
c'est d'abord à attendre le feu vert de
berlin et de paris avant de déposer
quelque chose ça ne va pas dans la crise
actuelle c'est la commission comme un
gouffre
européen qui doit prendre ses
responsabilités et deuxième ils
deuxièmement il faut aussi donner ses
droit d'initiative dans les années à
venir au parlement européen l'europe
fédérale dont vous rêvez est-ce que
c'est pas voeu pieux c'est pas un rêve
d'adolescent je sais bien que le mât
fédéralisme ça veut bien dire en france
nous sommes même une connotation
négative en tous cas ce qui est pour moi
l'état une europe fédérale c'est pas la
création d'un super état d'un super état
bureaucratique pour moi une intégration
européenne doit servir à faire au niveau
européen des choses où on peut créer un
plus value pour les citoyens les choses
qui peuvent être mieux fait au niveau
national au niveau local il faut le
faire au niveau local au niveau national
mais des choses par exemple les dépenses
militaires
là je serai beaucoup mieux de ce qu père
et de coordonner d'avoir pourquoi pas
une armée européenne ce serait en tout
cas moins coûteux et plus beaucoup plus
efficace les libéraux c'est la troisième
force à au parlement européen donc si
vous n'avez pas la majorité des voix aux
élections où vous allez vous alliez avec
qui les conservateurs du ppe ou avec les
sociétés à ce qu'ils veulent on sait
qu'au niveau économique vous êtes plutôt
pp mais au niveau sociétal vous êtes
plus plu c'est que on est au milieu et
au cendrillon que c'est nous qui faisons
ici dans ce parlement
les majorités ou bien à gauche ou bien à
droite qu'à choisir pour renforcer le
pacte de stabilité on a fait ça avec le
ppe mais de l'autre côté pour combattre
orban tous et le dire la dirif qu'on a
vue en hongrie
on a fait une alliance avec les
socialistes et moi je veux continuer
comme ça c'est je veux travailler avec
ces forces qui sont prêts à soutenir bon
programme c'est pour cette raison que
j'ai dit aux électeurs c'est important
de voter pour les libéraux puisque les
libéraux sont le centre vraiment de la
prise des décisions ou sa du parlement
européen ce sera le mot de la fin en
tout cas merci d'avoir accepté il
verhofstadt notre invitation
et maintenant place aux au reportage
après le référendum du 9 février dernier
qui réintroduit les quotas d'immigration
en suisse le dépit des frontaliers
français nous avons suivi pascal riou
tels les françaises elles travaillent en
suisse le traverse elle fait le trajet
tous les jours
elle s'inquiète un précepte cette
votation suisse le reportage de
charleville à 9
la roche sur foron une petite ville à la
frontière franco suisse
à l'heure où certains dorment encore
pascal se rend au travail si elle se
lève aussitôt c'est pour traverser la
frontière
tous les matins ils sont des dizaines de
transfrontalier à prendre le bus
destination genève un trajet de 45
minutes
je représente pas une façon de vivre
depuis 22 ans bientôt
trop de la connais par coeur au moment
de passer la douane petit pincement au
coeur
son sans faute en suisse est ce que
que française c'est une qualité de vie
que j'aime beaucoup
si pascal et anxieuse c'est à cause de
la votation anti immigration des suisses
le 9 février dernier en tant que
transfrontalière française elle est
directement concerné sa première
inquiétude le salaire les différences
entre la france et la suisse sont
considérables
c'est du simple au double tout
simplement des salaires c'est quasiment
doublé il ya beaucoup de salaires très
bas en france notamment au nouveau
secrétariat
ça c'est sûr donc c'est sûr de ce côté
là où ça serait vraiment une grosse
perte
principale mesure de cette votation la
mise en place de quotas une véritable
barrière à l'emploi pour pascal malgré
son expérience professionnelle
si je devais changer d'emploi refaire
par exemple une demande de permis à un
moment donné ça veut dire repasser
vraisemblablement à la case départ comme
ya quelques années et attendre la
réponse pour pouvoir retrouver un
travail en fonction des quotas dans
cette entreprise
on compte près de 20 transfrontalier
pour 140 employés suisses et étrangers
partagent les mêmes bureaux
la plupart se connaissent et ont du mal
à comprendre le résultat de cette
votation dans le fond qu'est ce qui les
différencie de nous qui habitons à 20
kilomètres de chez eux sauf qu'il ya
juste une ligne entre les deux puis ça
fait penser suisse il travaille comme
nous y même parfois il va porte plus
plus voilà où on leur prélève leurs
impôts la source
il n'y a rien
vois pas pourquoi en fait ils n'auraient
plus le droit de venir travailler
en suisse
philip young est l'un des dirigeants de
berne est associé l'homme d'affaires
voit dans cette votation un danger pour
les entreprises suisses ce que je
ressens au sein des associés c'est une
plus grande inquiétude parce que
aujourd'hui on travaille beaucoup aussi
pour des sociétés qui viennent
s'implanter en suisse alors qu'elles
soient est française américaine et
italienne c'est égal et beaucoup
d'entreprises one et s'implanter en
suisse il amenait des collaborateurs
donc pour ces entreprises là on devait
demander des permis de travail
et là il y aura peut-être une baisse en
fait dans nos volumes d'activité
ce projet anti immigration inquiète les
acteurs économiques de la suisse en
cause la main d'oeuvre étrangère
véritable poumon de plusieurs secteurs
d'activités comme le commerce
l'industrie ou encore l'agriculture dans
le pays
il y aurait plus de 150000 frontaliers
français 60 militaires liens et autant
d'allemands jean françois besson
représente et défend ses travailleurs
vont tout faire pour que la loi soit la
moins pénalisante possible pour leur
économie
donc si on a une économie qui continue à
se développer si les entreprises suisses
ont besoin de main d'oeuvre étrangère
on peut penser que la loi permettra
d'avoir des notions de quotas ou de
contingents qui seront suffisamment
large pour permettre de répondre à la
demande de l'économie plus largement
cette votation pourrait aussi remettre
en cause les accords bilatéraux avec
l'union européenne
le texte adopté ne précise ni
l'organisation des contingents ni quels
en seront les limites
le gouvernement suisse a trois ans pour
présenter un projet de loi pour le
moment son application reste très vague
voilà c'était un reportage de charles
villa neuve alors nous avons été
rejoints sur ce plateau par catherine
trautmann bonjour ans yanis de la
culture ancien maire de strasbourg vous
êtes eurodéputés socialistes à vos côtés
autant face de vous bruno gollnisch vous
êtes eurodéputés longtemps le numéro 2
du front national en france alors vous
avez vu le reportage de charles
villanove ce référendum en suisse c'est
quoi c'est guilhem guillaume tell qui se
trompe de de cible à coups de massue à
repli sur soi ou c'est plutôt
l'affirmation d'une souveraineté
nationale légitime alors l'expression de
guillaume tell qui se remet de sims
était le titre de mots communiqué je
suis là la paternité
je pense que ce vote a été exprimée dans
la crainte et dans là je dirais la
propagande qui a été menée pendant des
semaines et des semaines dans une
période de crise par rapport à un pays
qui se sent plus en fragilité
aujourd'hui par rapport au contexte dans
lequel il est et on constate aussi
d'ailleurs une certaine division entre
les électeurs ceux qui sont dans les
régions frontalières se sont exprimés
contre la proposition de limiter cette
immigration de masse par des quotas
tandis que ceux qui étaient plus à
l'intérieur du pays étaient alémaniques
se sont exprimés en faveur
c'est un coup de tonnerre et je crois
que c'est grave parce que il y a une
clause dans les accords avec l'union
européenne qui fait que tout accord
bilatéral avec la suisse est liée aux
autres
donc nous qui venons de délibérer sur
des programmes comme le programme
recherche comme le l'accès de la suisse
programme d'innovation nous avons un
professeur de lausanne qui doit piloter
la recherche sur le cerveau qui réunit
plusieurs laboratoires cela les suspens
nous avons également une autre
conséquence qui est la suspension des
discussions avec la croatie pour
l'alsace ce sont soixante mille
personnes frontalière qui sont concernés
et qui apporte comme cela était dans les
objets évidemment de la richesse à ce
pays
et ça comporte aussi parfois d'ailleurs
des inconvénients pour nous dans la
mesure dans certains métiers
l'attractivité des salaires nous fait
manquer de personnel je pense aux
infirmières par exemple ou à certains
métiers où les gens préfèrent aller
travailler un scout solaire pour
catherine trautmann je suppose que vous
n'êtes pas d'accord bruno gollnisch
non je crois d'abord si vous me le
permettez que si propagande il y avait
on le voit excusez moi monsieur tazir un
peu avec votre reportage et s'est
exercée de façon absolument unilatérales
à l'encontre de cette décision
majoritaire du peuple suisse prise sur
l'initiative populaire et qui témoigne
d'un remarquable sens de la démocratie
car enfin j'aurais eu le temps de vivre
juste faire tomber le gouvernement
le gouvernement les partis majoritaires
au parlement suisse ont donné leur
analyse au peuple le peuple s'est
prononcé après un débat de façon tout à
fait libre et ça n'est pas du tout la
catastrophe que décrit madame trautmann
à moins évidemment qu'on ait décidé de
l'ostraciser les suisses en effet ce que
je trouve curieux d'ailleurs dans les
réactions médiatiques c'est que on ne
donne la parole comme votre reportage
qu'aux gens qui sont défavorables à
d'habitude quand il ya une compétition
politique et qui est un vainqueur quand
même les micros et les caméras se
tendent un petit peu vers celui qui a
gagné on lui demande pourquoi il a fait
cela quels angles du ciel le sujet ces
anglais comme on dit dans la profession
devraient suivre
un travailleur frontalière de quoi elles
sont plutôt d'éviter de quoi s'agit-il
il s'agit simplement d'un article que
j'ai ici de la constitution suisse un
nouvel article est insérée dans la
constitution suisse et qui dit que les
suisses en quelque sorte renationaliser
leur politique d'immigration la suisse
est un pays où il ya huit millions
d'habitants
un million neuf cent mille étrangers
c'est donc considérable 25% de la
population
les suisses avaient envisagé et conclu
un accord de libre circulation des
personnes avec l'union européenne
et ils s'aperçoivent que depuis cet
accord là le bilan des étrangers qu'ils
restent sur leur territoire est dix fois
supérieur à ce qu'ils attendaient prévu
alors il donne la possibilité aux
instances nationales en excluant tout
accord international de prendre les
décisions qui s'imposent qui seront du
domaine de la loi la personne que vous
nous avez montré à mon avis n'a
absolument aucun souci à se faire
les contingents seront fixées
annuellement
ils ne le sont pas aux normes et ils le
sont simplement en fonction des intérêts
économiques de la suisse
juste une dernière chose si vous le
permettez j'ai vu que la personne en
question mais dit mais je vais
travailler en suisse parce qu'en suisse
les salaires
sont deux fois plus élevés qu'en france
mais je pense que si en france il y
avait moins de dumping social due à une
concurrence effrénée qui est fait
nécessairement par des travailleurs
étrangers prêts à travailler pour moins
cher que qu'il ne le faudrait et bien
les salaires serait peut-être un peu
plus élevé vous avez vous suivre bruno
gollnisch j'ai les miens aussi elle veut
donner à nos téléspectateurs pour qu'ils
puissent comprendre la suisse ces 8
millions d'habitants 80 mille nouveaux
arrivants chaque année les 900 milles
les étrangers les plus nombreux se sont
en suisse ce sont les italiens 280 11000
les allemands 284 milles puis les
portugais les français 104/1000 c'est 40
% des nouvelles entreprises en suisse
sont créés par des étrangers
ces entreprises qui ont créé plus de
30000 emplois en 2013 c'était trop tous
à bruno gollnisch
non mais écoutez c'est le problème et le
problème n'est pas là le problème est de
savoir est ce que le peuple suisse a le
droit de conserver de maintenir son
identité
serait ce à l'égard de gens extrêmement
sympathique comme les français que je
défends par ailleurs moi je défends les
intérêts des français mais je ne sais
par contre a dit non parce que je le
fais en fonction de principes universels
la prairie fonds dont les intérêts
nationaux des français je comprends très
bien que les suisses défendent leurs
propres intérêts voilà c'est aussi
simple que cela écrit trautmann oui moi
je défends les intérêts des français et
je défends les intérêts des français qui
sont des travailleurs frontaliers comme
je défends qu' on ne peut pas passer un
accord de libre échange sans la
circulation des personnes
on y voit très bien alors sur l'accord
de libre échange et ça a été signé avec
la suisse et que la votation à l'époque
a été largement positif bien plus
positive que la dernière votation
limitant l'immigration on a eu une
envolée de l'économie suisse menait donc
un moment donné on ne peut pas dire je
prends une partie je laisse le mayen
fait dirige plaisir entre les ans et je
vais et je ne sais je vais laisser les
autres de l'or s'est lui affiché sa veut
dire que la suisse sa roseraie le droit
de faire une différence entre les
citoyens européens qui ont adhéré aux
mêmes lois aux mêmes droits et aux mêmes
possibilités de développement je suis
européen mais je pense que c'est une
façon de lutter contre le dumping
mais je suis pour le respect on ne peut
pas avoir la sans avoir l'autre mais
vous nous dites vous nous dites madame
précisément que la situation antérieure
était très bénéfique pour la suisse
c'est parce que c'est bénéfique pour la
suisse elle est un peu moins pour nous
alors vous étiez au suisse qu elle est
aussi contre vous voulez absolument
faire au suisse un cadeau dont ils ne
veulent pas ou dont ils ne veulent plus
justement le même où le délégué excusez
moi et vous le faites madame trautmann
quand même en les menaçant
parce que et c'est ça que je trouve
assez dérisoire vous dites vous dites on
ne peut pas avoir des accords
économiques sans la libre circulation
des personnes
et pourquoi c'est parce que vous l'avez
décidé qu'est ce qui s'est passé
autrement ce sont les bases du marché
unique et des traités de l'union
européenne que vous contestez vous
voulez sortir de l'euro vous voulez en
fait sortir la france de 100 de son
environnement européen
moi je pense que le cas suisse montre la
limite de votre politique de vos
propositions enfin parce que finalement
qui défend les intérêts des français moi
aussi monsieur gollnisch
parce que les frontaliers c'est moi qui
les défendent pas vous mènent en
défendant les quotas vous êtes contre le
travail
vous êtes responsable d'une politique
par exemple je donnais les responsables
politiques manger ce que je dis j'ai
fait un devis chez moi pour refaire les
joints des pierres de ma grange et bien
parmi les maçons que j'ai contacté y en
a un qui m'a dit monsieur gollnisch
quel que soit le prix le devis que vous
font mes concurrents moi je vous fais 30
% moins cher parce que je fais
travailler des polonais et je fais
travailler d'épaulé au tarif de la
sécurité polonaise alors ne dit pas je
vous en prie que vous défendez les
français nous défendons tous les
français le problème les français au
niveau européen le problème c'est de
savoir s'il y a une libre détermination
des peuples il quand même je voudrais je
vais me suis posé à madame trautmann
question nous étions vraiment comment
faisait on avant
comment faisait ton avant sa signature
de ce traité de libre circulation des
personnes
est-ce qu'il n'y avait pas du commerce
avec la switch il n'y avait pas la même
le même niveau de commerce
et lorsque les suisses ont une votation
pour approuver les accords bilatéraux à
62% et que la à un peu plus de 50%
il refuse l'une des composantes
essentielles de l'accord qui a été
soutenue par les suisses eux mêmes je
dis parfois il y à des votations qui
démontre
que l'on peut se tromper aussi maman
démocratie la parole des autorités
suisses qui sont dans une grande
difficulté aujourd'hui parce que ils ne
peuvent pas être un obstacle à
l'évolution européenne après donc la rdc
on bloquera ce mu comme ça et de
recherche
non ce ne sont pas des représailles
attention ce sont pas du tout du tout la
suisse et les autorités suisses savait
pertinemment que toutes les clauses
liées à l'ensemble des accords
bilatéraux étaient liés que lorsque la
suisse voulait disposer du marché unique
et d'une entrée absolument ouverte est
libéralisée elle avait des obligations
notamment celle de reconnaître vous
allez vous n'allez pas me dire qu'il est
conforme aux intérêts de l'europe par
exemple que l'on supprime le traité avec
la suisse sur l'assurance décès sur la
double sur la non double imposition
je vais vous donner un exemple des
représailles car ce sont des repousses
association des jeunes dont il s'agit
bien sûr des billets sont soumises à
cannes on veut faire peur aux suisses et
à tout l'été à travers la suisse
c'est pour ça que vous disiez que
c'était très grave à travers la semaine
en hiver parce que vous êtes déçu c'est
certain
tous les peuples qui veulent re re
conquérir leur indépendance soit 2,7 et
lancions une victoire a donné jusqu'à ce
que je dis là n'est qu'à ces élections
sur l'électricité est heureux se
rappelait le traité sur l'électricité
aux menaces il ya un traité sur
l'électricité aux menaces de le
suspendre avec la suisse les premiers
ennuyé ce sont les allemands qui ont
suspendu leurs programmes nucléaires et
qui compte bien acheter l'électricité
platini je pense qu'on est encore à
venir pour conclure que c'est lent et
prévenez moi qu'est que c'est un choix
qui est pénalisant d'abord pour les
suisses eux mêmes pour l'économie suisse
et pour l'évolution de ce pays
je pense que la suisse a sa place dans
l'europe mais que cette place en porte
des droits et des responsabilités qui
sont les mêmes pour les européens et
pour les suisses c'est ça l'europe et en
sortir sans porte des conséquences
négatives et c'est une bonne
démonstration avant les élections
européennes
parce qu'on voit que le parti de
monsieur denis amène vers une impasse et
vert précisément une situation nouvelle
qui risque de l'autre transitoire on est
ronde et suis greffé random couleurs
la politique vous mettra par la classe
politique ont donné un magnifique on
vous mettra pas d'accord si d'avoir
accepté notre invitation pour débattre
on en reparlera bien évidemment dans les
jours qui viennent c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi la
prochaine la semaine prochaine vous
retrouvez n'aura hamadi à cette même
place dans ce nouveau studio
d'ici là bonne suite des programmes sur
les chaînes parlementaires
je pense que les politiques qui
commencent leur interview en disant non
non j'ai aucune ambition et je suis
super gentil